>> Good morning everybody.
It is my great pleasure to
welcome Joanna Bryson to
Microsoft Research today,
for her to give her talk,
and she's going to be
spending the day here
talking to a bunch of us.
She is an Associate Professor
at the University of Perth,
and she is a trusted
disciplinary researcher
focusing on many
different problems,
many problems that are
very interesting to us
at the intersection
of AI psychology,
autonomy, ethics of robotics
and human cooperation
collaboration.
So, I'll welcome her to talk
about her fascinating research,
and if you have questions during
the talk please free
to ask. Thank you.
>> Well, thank you. I'm
not using that microphone.
Okay. Thanks for having me here.
I have as usual a lot of slides.
So, I'll just get into
it, please do ask.
But thanks very much, everybody
involved inviting me.
Originally Jamie, but it's
become a very team effort.
So, yeah you may
think it's weird that I'm talking
about the European Union.
But I'm just taking it as
another interesting
political entity,
and they are these very
specific goals which
are human dignity
and flourishing.
I don't know about you,
when I first heard about
these goals it sounded
like you know like you
know vaporware right.
Like what does that even mean.
Right? But I've come to
realize that sort of
what it means is
that everybody needs
at least enough stability in
their lives so that
they can plan,
so that they can
build a business.
So, they can decide
whether to have a family.
Not that everybody needs
a family but that you can
have these kinds of
things as options, right?
So, there's something that we
need in order to flourish,
and we've been doing a pretty
good job of flourishing.
Do I get a laser? I
could just point.
So, this is the log
scale population
in millions of humans.
It started from 10,000 years ago.
Does anyone have a laser that
they're carrying around?
Oh, here it is. I found one.
So, yeah.
So, what happened
10,000 years ago,
up until 10,000 years ago,
we were being
out-competed by monkeys.
Monkeys evolved more
recently than humans.
There were more macaques
than hominids,
and then all of a
sudden, we got writing,
agriculture urbanization and
then dark channel religion
as an AI person I'd like to
think the writing
is the key thing.
But I like to talk
about writing as
the first AI because it
was was off-board memory.
It allowed us to innovate
and then all of a
sudden we get this.
Amazing, so we're flourishing.
Right. As we know,
sometimes you might
also think about this,
an exponential, that's
super-intelligence, right?
As we've all heard,
my fellow immigrant
colleague in the UK,
there is sometimes
unanticipated sub-goals
of super-intelligence,
and one is the we're wiping out
of all the other large animals.
You can see that even before
that 100,00 years ago,
when humans got to continent
it was sometimes bad news,
but actually, some of that is
because there was actually
another bit of
global warming right then.
So, maybe the reason we
were moving so much was
because there was
reasons to go and
that was hard. But look at this.
There's actually more biomass now
especially since
the industrial revolution we're
actually taking energy out
of the ground and out of
the sky and things and
creating more biomass,
but we're converting it
entirely into people
and livestock.
So, this is another
unanticipated sub-goal.
It's the green boxes there.
This is from a few years ago.
Are all the wild animals there
left, wild mammals, okay.
Of course, another
unanticipated sub-goal is
that we have started helping
produce even more climate
change and that kind of
thing brings all kinds
of things we
don't really necessarily want.
All right. I've got to say it,
all that is not only
because of climate,
there's lots of things
that drive that change.
One of the things is the economy.
So, sometimes we
have these periods
with very high inequality,
and that tends to correlate with
very high political polarization
and identity politics.
So, periods of
very great volatility.
So, this is World War One,
does anyone want to guess
why we have numbers going
back to World War One?
There was this crazy thing
where we outlawed alcohol,
and when we outlawed alcohol,
we needed more tax so
we create income tax.
So, since the innovation
of the income tax,
we know what proportion of
wealth has gone to
the top one percent,
and we can see that
that correlates pretty
well with the amount of
political polarization.
This is measured by
whether or not the two
houses of Congress,
for both houses of Congress,
the two parties, both their
names are on bills.
Okay, so that's
a particular measure due to
Nolan McCarty and
actually his PhD supervisor
as he's now professor
at Princeton.
Anyway, these are
pretty well correlated
and there's some interesting
things going on there,
but we, in the 30s,
in both the US and the UK,
we managed to get
our act together
and reduce both inequality
and the polarization,
and we kept it down
until about 1978
and then we've
started launching up
again on both of those measures.
I think this is history.
But I think that part
of the reason there's
more of a gap here than there,
is because this is measured
income inequality but probably
wealth inequality is
what does the drive-in.
All right. So, we don't have
income for a longer
time but we do have
polarization since the Civil War
and more broadly we can look
at people believe
they have inequality.
I don't know if I
believe the Y axis
here and that you can really
match it up this way.
Famously, there are some papers
here Scheidel claiming
that you have to have
war and mayhem or else you don't
get reductions of inequality.
But I think that things
like this matters,
see that shift in the- ?
This was between wars
when we did that.
So, I think we can do
things with policy to
reduce inequality and
polarization as well.
So, yeah, why do we care?
One reason we care and this
has just come out
in the last year,
it's been a big question.
We know there's a correlation.
What the causation is
has been a big question.
One of the things we know is
that extreme physicians and
politicians are driven by
extreme positions in
major single donors.
So, one of the things that
inequality does is increase
this number of people who can
be such major single donors.
Right? Because there's
relatively few people
with large amounts of
money and this has been changing
spectacularly in
the last couple of decades.
All right. So, you've probably
wondered by this point,
"Is she going to talk
about AI or not?" Right?
So, mostly I've been talking
about right now, so far,
is setting the groundwork
with the impediment to
a stable society part.
Now, I'm not going
to talk about AI,
I'm just going to talk
about intelligence.
So, I realized this
is Microsoft Research,
I don't mean to pander,
but this is a slide
I already had and
I was lazy, but also,
I think it's
interesting to see that
you can pitch it this way.
So, I like to remind people that
intelligence is relying on
computation and not math.
A lot of people just assume
that intelligence
can be spontaneous,
it's absolutely true that AI is
necessarily going to be
unbiased and neutral,
and they're mistaking
algorithms for math,
and math for computation.
So, computation is
a physical process,
it's a transformation
of information.
Any physical process takes
time, energy, and space.
We all know this is sort
of the Patrick Winston
about what not that
there's anything
wrong with that version of AI,
but finding the right thing
to do at the right time,
which is the fundamental problem
of intelligence,
is a form of search.
The cause search is the number
of options versus number of acts.
So, that's why, again,
you guys know this,
that means that if
you have a robot
that can do 100 things,
and then it gets a two step plan,
there's 10,000 possible
plans already.
But believe me, you give
this slide to a politicians even,
people who are pretty well
informed and they're stunned.
The whole thing about 35 moves
against the chest,
not moving the rock
back and forth.
People don't understand this.
So, you guys, being at Microsoft,
are probably thinking "Hasn't
she heard about the Cloud yet?"
The concurrency can
save on real time,
but it obviously,
you have the time,
you double the amount of
space you require and that
energy requirements
are a constant.
Weirdly, people aren't even
talking about what's
going on with quantum.
Again, it's going to
be this magic thing,
it's going to solve our stuff.
It does seem to save on space.
Once, for some subset
of problems,
you can solve things
in a single computer.
But so far, it looks
like the energy is more
than the space loss.
Although there's not enough
good work done on this.
So, this is my personal
captor quantum physicist,
but I've given
this talk to a lot of
places and nobody has told
me I'm wrong about this.
But basically, nobody is doing
math on the energy
problems of quantum.
So, yes. Omniscience is not
actually a real threat.
That's not the problem.
Again, I probably don't need
to tell anyone in this room,
but I have been in DC where
people were talking about,
"What if one country finds
the machine learning algorithm,
and suddenly knows
all the things."
Then, that somehow there'd be
no way to recover from that.
National Intelligence
is not general.
Again, I wrote the slide
talk yesterday and nobody
said this to me, this might.
Nobody has so far and
the three people I've talked
to has mentioned of AGI.
But anyway, I'll mention it.
Early in psychology, we thought
that any stimulus could
provoke any response.
We were wrong.
It turns out pigeons can
learn to peck for food,
and deflect their wings
to avoid shock.
Incidentally, not
every pigeon can learn this.
Most pigeons don't
peck that much.
That's actually the genius
pigeons who also that
were used for all those
experiments you've seen.
People tell you, "Oh, pigeons."
But anyway, pigeons can
learn to peck for food,
they can not learn
to peck in order to
avoid shock or to flap
their wings for food.
That doesn't make sense
if you're a pigeon.
Those kinds of things are stuff
you would never need to know.
So, if those activity
is not there,
your brain doesn't provide you
the bias to do
that kind of learning.
So, yeah.
This is the advantage of
science over some other
sources of knowledge.
Okay. Now, that we
understand combinatorics,
this is one of the big questions
I had as an undergraduate.
Why is it that the brain,
given that there's
evolution and everything,
why hasn't the brain settled
down on one architecture?
Why haven't we figured
out the best way
to represent information?
Why is there different activity
in different parts of the brain?
Well, different parts
of the brain
are solving different problems.
So, there's going to be different
optimal solutions to
these different problems.
So, of course, you're going
to get different activity
in different
representations and things.
Nobody really, when you
think about a heart,
expects that the whole brain
is going like one giant retina.
Come on, it's just
doing different stuff.
So, that also explains
why some level of bias,
even prejudice, is
a necessary part of AI.
Again, I think you guys
know about this work,
but I don't know.
How many of you people know
about my science paper,
the one about that word
embeddings have prejudice?
Okay. How many people know about
your guy's paper that
came out that, well,
it hit our archives at
the same time but went NIPS?
Okay. So, there was,
for those of you don't know, that
was entirely
an overlapping group.
But within everyone. All right.
So, I will do this a little bit.
So, if you just use
word embeddings,
which is basically
a giant vector.
I'm going to show
you a picture later.
So, you basically just sit around
and count whether words,
or how words co-occur
next to each other,
you recover the things that
scientists call implicit biases.
So, we took every single
study we could find.
This is because
the first author was
a Princeton postdoc and
the final author was up
for tenure this year
at Princeton.
Every single paper that had
the implicit association
test in it and used words,
and used them on
the general population.
Because we were using the Web,
and we couldn't tell who
had written what part of the Web,
so, we could only use
general population results.
But we matched
every single one of them.
So, this for example, is showing,
you have a bunch of women's
names representing women,
and men's names representing men,
and family words representing
the domestic sphere,
and career words representing
the corporate sphere.
Then you find, if the world
was a perfectly fair place,
if you give them the task
of matching words up,
they should be just as fast at
matching up women to
career and men to family,
as the other way around,
but in fact they're much faster
at doing women to career,
to family, and men to career.
So, this is them being
faster like regular people,
and d is a measurement in
terms of standard deviation.
Because we don't have a theory
of how long that should
take but we just look and say,
"Are these two things different?"
So, we see the normal
distribution, we say,
"How far apart are those
two normal distributions?"
These are giants. This is huge.
When people say, "Oh,
this is the real effect."
What are they talking about?
This is one of the biggest
effects in psychology,
implicit association test,
and people are say
it's fake news.
Because, it doesn't correlate
perfectly with
explicit prejudice.
I think that's because
people don't know
the difference between implicit,
and explicit memory
anymore which we
got tired if you're old
as I am in college.
Anyway, so the point is
that they were saying this,
and I still get people who hammer
me when I give that talk.
I didn't think I needed
to give that talk here,
saying, "Don't you know that
you can't trust psychology?"
Totally different method,
doing word counting,
large purpose linguistics,
the same stuff, latent,
and semantic analysis,
the way that we do
search for web pages.
We were able to replicate,
well, replicate is not
quite the right word.
Also find evidence of
bias in the words.
The headlines all said AI is
prejudice and
the good headline said,
"It is because of us."
But that wasn't
really the finding.
The real finding was
that words or word use,
what we pass on to other people,
as well as to machines,
contains the image,
not only of our implicit
biases, but actually,
and this is something completely
down to that final author,
I mentioned Divya
Narayanan, he said,
"I want to see what happens
with something that's real."
So, the Y axis here is
the same awful prejudice word
embeddings that
gave us that women are closer to
the domestic sphere than
to the work sphere.
So, those exact same
things, but then,
we went out and looked at
the 2015 US labor statistics,
which unfortunately,
weren't all single terms,
and this only works
for single term.
So, we had to just throw
away the adjectives.
So, that's why there's
some of the noise,
but, 90 percent correlation.
Again, if you're in psychology,
that's a huge deal.
Ninety percent correlation,
in predicting how male
or female a word was,
this is a programmer
unfortunately.
When I was a programmer,
we were 13 percent
of the population,
women were, and this is the '80s.
It went up it and peaked around
18-19 percent, it's crashed.
It's four or five percent,
it's just appalling.
I don't know why and
there's a lots of
women in the audience.
Programming is fun.
I love programming.
I don't know what's happened.
Anyway. So, yeah.
This is like being a nurse
or something up here.
Fortunately, being a doctor,
is over here somewhere.
But anyway, I learned
a lot last summer.
But the point is, that
our implicit biases turn out to
reflect the current reality
in some cases, not all of them.
That's interesting. It's cool.
Because going back to the
implicit, explicit divide,
that means that we can
explicitly decide,
"Oh, we want to employ women.
We think it's good for women
to be able to have jobs,
and we can try to shift
to something new."
But the implicit biases seem to
be bootstrapping off
of observed reality,
or historic reality,
or something.
So, go ahead and ask
me more questions.
But anyway, that wasn't going
to be the point at this talk.
Sorry. So, the point is that,
when you're a member of
a cognitive species, then,
it makes sense for you to exploit
the concurrent computation
that others are doing.
Again, I didn't have time,
I put way too many
slides into this,
but, I have a beautiful video,
ask me if you want it in Q&A,
of tortoises learning
from each other,
and they're not very smart.
These tortoises are not smart,
but when they see
a tortoise solve
a problem, they solve
the problem too.
It's a problem they
couldn't solve for a month.
So, it just makes sense.
This is the way to think
about what culture is;
it's the exploitation of
computations already been done.
So, we can do this
explicitly with students
or apprentices,
I just mentioned you can have
implicit social learning,
even if they're
really stupid things
like reptiles and fish.
Sorry I didn't put
a reference in there,
just ask me for
the references if you want.
One of the things that's
going on is we've
implicit sensitivity
to social examples,
and I think that's
what's going on with
the overactive
anthropomorphism of AI, okay?
So, now, I'll come down
and start actually
talking about artificial
intelligence, all right?
I think, yeah. Not quite.
Almost. Just before AI.
I was asked to give a keynote
at RoboPhil which you'll
probably have heard of it,
but it's actually a fairly
big meeting of philosophers
and people working
on social robots.
So, things that are supposed
to look like people and
participate in
human society, okay?
This is the fourth or
fifth time that it's met,
I think it is a biannual.
But it's the first
time they met in
Vienna and it's the first time
they invited more general
scientists to it.
They titled it this year,
Politics, Power, and
the Public Space.
Okay, speaking of public spaces,
this is a statue
by Seward Johnson.
He produced a whole lot
of statues in
the '70s and put them
into public spaces.
In the '70s, that
was going a little
dicey in some of
these public spaces.
It turned out that if
you put something looked
like a person into
a public space,
you've made that space safer.
People felt more like there
was another person
around, all right?
That's the statue, okay?
A lot of philosophers had
this huge thing about
intuition like you can tell
that a robot is a person,
you can tell that.
How could you be
denying something,
denying rights to
something that you can
feel is definitely a person?
You feel the statue is
a person too, okay?
You can show that you
feel that because it
alters your behavior, all right?
So, over scaled statues
fascinate yet diminish us.
That's something
Seward Johnson actually said.
So, he got bored of making
human scale once he started
taking pieces of art
and employing them up.
It's really cool.
Those are my parents
hanging out at the statue.
This a place in New Jersey
called Grounds for Sculpture.
So, yeah.
There's a concept from
psychology, again,
just being this, super
normal stimulus,
that if you have something
that you evolved to attend
to and that you never go into
an evolutionary history,
if it's something that was
a greater example of that,
you can actually over
respond to it and
your biology doesn't shut
you down from doing that.
Arguably, we've been doing things
like this for a long time.
So, what happens with AI?
This is how I got into AI ethics.
So, I have a couple
degrees in psychology
but I also a couple
degrees in AI.
When I started my PhD,
I was on this project,
this robot, at the time
that I was on it and
at the time this picture
was taken, did not work.
This is basically a sculpture
made out of motors, okay?
But it turns out there was
all these processors
that were supposed
to be at sprain
and it turned out they
weren't properly grounded.
So, anyway, the
whole time I was on
the project, it didn't work.
Yet people would walk by and say,
"It would be unethical
to unplug that."
They were proud to know
that they had this
certain knowledge that,
I couldn't unplug
this thing, all right?
They generalize from feminism
and the civil rights movement.
They found out that
the most unlikeliest things
turn out to be people, right?
That they could just
say, "Oh, yeah.
Well, obviously, if
a woman could be a person,
then this is too, right?"
So, anyway. Yeah.
There's something
really strange going on here.
They really, really get angry if
you say that this
is not a person,
and that they say
that we have a right
to fall in love
with these things,
we have a right to have our
best friends that we can buy;
that we can buy and
sell citizens, right?
So, I think this is both
sick and dangerous.
I say that as somebody who
seriously would thought
she was going to
dedicate an entire PhD to
making this into
a child, all right?
So, I realize, I get
it, I've been there.
But, you can read some
of the papers about this
Kathleen Richardson
particular talks
about this in
the feminist context.
So, this is me back then.
If you're young like
that, now be aware.
But that robot on the left,
the robot on the right didn't
work at the time, it
did eventually work.
The one on the left
already worked,
nobody ever said like, "Oh,
to be honest, I can unplug
the insect robots."
Even though they actually worked,
they were smarter in
some sense, right?
So, yeah, and I've
got an unplug code.
My supervisor at that time,
again, I didn't finish with him.
I call a conservative for saying
robots might not take over.
People were absolutely certain
that robots were going
to take over, right?
This is now, again,
random people.
This was people on
a panel he was on of
other scientists and
philosophers and AI builders.
Okay. So, because of all this,
I wrote with the only
philosopher I knew at the time.
We wrote this in 1996.
It took us forever to get it into
the crappiest possible workshop.
Then, finally, we did a rewrite
and reboot and put it
into IJCAI more recently.
But this is 1998 text.
"We believe exaggerated
fears of and hopes
for AI are symptomatic
of a larger problem,
a general confusion
about the nature of
humanity and the role
of ethics in society.
Our thesis is that
these exaggerated fears are
false concerns which
can distract us from
the real dangers of
AI technologies."
Often, I get cast as
somebody who is saying,
"Oh, there's nothing to
worry about with AI."
I don't know, you're worrying
about the wrong things
with AI, right?
"The real dangers are
no different though
from those of other artifacts
so potential for misuse,
either through carelessness or
malevolence by the people
who control them."
All right. So this is
a slide that I wrote when
I started giving talks
because of the things
people were saying
about our AI biased paper
that came out, right?
So, a lot of people
said, "Oh, look,
this is terrible
because society is bad,
therefore AI is going to be bad."
So, yes, you can have
biases in this case.
I don't like to use
biases but anyway.
They absorbed automatically by
a machine learning
from ordinary culture.
That's true, that's
one source of them.
There's also
accidental bias that's
being introduced
through ignorance by,
for example, the Kate Crawford
insufficiently diverse
development team.
Yes, that's also a problem.
But the main thing I
worry about is that
she could deliberately
introduce bias.
Somebody could say, "Hey,
I've been elected only
by the people from
the East Coast or
the east side of town,
let's figure out a way to save
money and let's just
take it on the west side
because they weren't
voting for me anyway so we
don't need to worry
about that," right?
You can come and do that.
If you forget that AI is
something somebody built,
then nobody is going to guess,
nobody is going to notice, right?
Nobody was talking about this,
they were all sitting there in
the New York Times talking about
a Silicon Valley's
problem with lack of
diversity which is an issue
but it's not the issue.
It's an issue. Right. Yeah, by
the way, back to
what I was saying.
Yeah, this is the most bypass
I had by magnitude
ever and
the malevolence AI book,
It's come out since then.
But, yeah, malevolence, right?
Malevolence, deliberate,
right. So, anyway,
ethical instincts
and ethics itself
we claimed was rooted
in identity, right?
That's something
a lot of people said.
We, humans mistakenly place
language mathematics
and reason as
the core of humanity because it
discriminates us from animals
and then we can use
them in stuff, right?
We thought back in 1996 as
a civil who wrote this,
that once we have
empirical experience of
AI this confusion is
probably going to go away.
We're talking about
like, how can we get
children the experience
of building AI,
young so they can be
smarter about this?
Right. Then, maybe even we'd
start informing our human ethics.
So, the sound is not coming on.
So, this is just
an undergraduate funding a course
on Intelligent Control
and Cognitive Systems.
But they didn't develop
these robots to be social,
they had just been doing in
a room but listen to them.
>> It's incredible.
>> I like how it does.
>> I don't know if
you're picking this up,
to me it's pretty
clear to me that
these guys are identifying
with the robots they have built.
They are projecting
themselves into
the space and it's as
if they were there,
that they're falling over.
They're saying these things,
they're seeing
themselves in their robots,
they're running around.
I was talking at
the same to them,
those robots were built by
them individually for
their projects and then we had
this thing called the Beauty
Competition at the end
of the year to decide
which robots don't have
to be dismantled but rather can
be used to attract freshmen to
University of Bath and to
live for another year.
The Beauty Competition
space that we bring
three naive people who don't
know anything about AI.
One year we used the theory of
computation people group to
look at the robots
and see which one looks most
intelligent from the outside.
Okay. So, anyway, the point is
that the students are seeing
their robots doing
something they've
never done before
which is interact with
other robots and they
project themselves into it.
We get this final year student at
a leading computer science
undergraduate to create,
in Britain, who has
built and programmed
to run it themselves,
talking about loving this robots.
Okay. So, I'm sure
you can make some kind
of association here.
I think that at least
for developers,
that we could have like
the movie actor dissociation,
but it's that clear to me in
fact you know anyone who
is an actor knows that
not everybody can make
the movie character actor
dissociation anyway.
Right, it's not clear
what's happening to
people when we put
robots out there
that they're able to tell
that there's this narrative
that we like to play and then
there's the reality
of the robot. Yes.
>> I don't think
it's just AI though,
I've done a study of programmers
debugging distributed systems
and they say things like,
"The server says this" and then
"The client says that", right?
I don't know if they're
anthropomorphizing it,
so much as just it's
a useful vocabulary,
like it's just a useful metaphor
for describing the technology?
>> That's certainly true.
That's actually
a really difficult problem
especially if you start
becoming known for this stuff.
You will hear, I have
to go back through
my proofs and make sure that
I haven't done that all the time,
because of course
it was easier to
say the car once knew
this or whatever.
So, that is ordinary
language. You're right.
But, when it becomes something
that an awful lot of
ordinary culture has told
people really is a person,
then I think it starts to become
confusing and so that's why I
do go back to my proofs and
try to make that change.
But, yeah.
I remember when we
used to say like
multi-agency systems is
going to be a new way to do
software engineering because
it helps people think better
about especially in
pro-active context,
real time pro-active contexts,
the responsibilities of the
different part of the system.
If they can use
social reasoning on
those different aspects and
there's all this
nice anthropology,
showing that we're
better at musing about
humans than about abstractions.
So anyway, I think this is
the way I currently
think, what's going on.
So, I sort of
mentioned this before,
intelligence is doing
the right thing at
the right time and
Artificial Intelligence.
The only difference between
that and natural is
that it's an artefact,
it was deliberately made.
Right. So, agents are
just a vector of change.
We don't care about agency.
What we care about
is moral agents.
Okay? The moral agent
is the thing that
a society holds responsible
for their actions.
Now, a lot of people think,
when you get into ethics that
there is some absolute ethics
that we're all
converging towards.
That somebody has written down
a set of rules and
carved it in stone,
and we just need
to figure it out.
But, I can give you
very clear examples of
moral agency being different
between societies which is that,
what age is a child responsible
for their own actions.
Okay? Massive disagreement
about a fundamental question,
between cultures, even
how old do you need to
be to say that you want to be
married or to consent to sex.
Right? This is something that we
spend a lot of time
trying to figure out.
So moral agency is something that
a society works out for itself.
While patients see similarly as
the other side is
what are the things we
feel responsible for?
Now, the interesting thing
is that these together
are moral subjects and if
you look at for example,
Roman law, they sort of say,
"You're only a moral or
a legal patient if
you're a legal agent".
That the law is about us,
but that's the opposite of
psychological intuitions,
so people feel that there's
more patiency where
there's less agency.
So, we all are supposed to be
helping babies and a lot of
people don't feel obliged to
adults that have addiction
problems or whatever
they're like,
"Hey, come on they're
an adult they should take
care of it themselves."
So, these are the definitions
to see if we have
a clear conversation
about what the
actual problems are.
Okay. Now this is all just true.
This is a weird thing
that people hate.
Okay? So, my claim is that,
ethics is a set of behaviors
that creates and
sustains a society,
including by defining
its identity.
That's why we get hung up on
some of the things like okay,
the British don't eat horses.
They don't. The people in
Eastern Europe they do.
But it's a big deal. Yeah.
>> Probably this is not
your main point but do you
think visual illusion is
a part of intelligence?
>> Sorry, visual illusions?
>> Illusions, yeah.
>> Well, I think it's
a part of art. Yeah.
Yes. That's an
interesting question
that's not directly on
the current narrative,
so let's save it for
the Q and A. Okay?
>> Thanks.
>> All right. So, ethics
is something that a society
develops to stabilize itself.
There are things that will be,
this includes general principles.
Right? Like murder and
theft and things like that
tend to destabilize the society,
any society, so societies
will tend to converge
on those kinds of rules.
But then as I said, one
of the things that helps
you keep your society together
is by maintaining this identity,
deciding who is a
part of your society.
That is actually one
of the things by
which a society defends itself.
I mean you could
think of it as the
original part of governance,
is that the main thing that
governance does is allocate
resources to defining
an identity for a group,
to build some kind of defenses
around a village or something.
Right? That's that sort of
redistribution and
security or the sort of
the central things
that are defining
a society so it can function
in particular ways.
>> Is it fair to
say that ethics are
necessary but not sufficient?
>> What I'm claiming here,
is that all the
behaviors by which we
maintain the society,
I'm just calling those ethics.
So, to extent that,
you need behavior and this is
kind of a weird definition,
this is an eccentric one for
communicating now this is not
what you're going to
find in the dictionary.
But to the extent that
you need behavior,
to help the society do
you need other things,
is that sufficient, while
you need the individuals.
So, there has to be a society,
society is made of something.
>> I will give you very,
very tough type for example,
you can have two set
of very diverge of
those ethics that are collocated.
Most states, most people
have very different beliefs.
Is there a society
or two societies?
>> Right. That's
a really interesting question,
so as you say.
So, to some extent there are
sub societies within
that and then there is
the super society which
has presumably some part of
the intersection that in
some other roles
too including just
being enforced by
the state powers.
So, yes. So, okay.
>> What is the role of
change in that fix?
Like the temporal change.
Because this definition
is kind of seeking
for something more like static.
>> No. No, it's not.
Actually, yes, change
is a big issue.
I don't want to go
into great detail,
but the whole reason that I was
setting this definition up,
which I don't
actually go into that
much in the rest of the talks,
so I'll go ahead
and say this here,
it's because given
that ethics is itself
an artifact and the AI is
definitionally an artifact,
there's no fact of
the matter of where we
stick AI into society.
That's not a scientifically
discoverable fact.
It's rather something that
we need to be optimizing.
So, this comes in to where
your and my research
is similar that
we keep doing things like that
are improving that solution.
So, the whole reason I'm saying
this is to get it to people.
Because while you
think that ethics is
a static target that
you're moving towards,
that you're just perfecting,
believe me you can get
professional philosophers that are
really angry about the stuff
that will get up and
say something like,
"We now know better
than people knew
in the 1940's or whatever."
We know some things better.
I'm not one of those people whose
a complete cultural relativists.
I do believe that we are
aggregating more information.
But I wouldn't say that we have
the perfect ethics
or that that's even
definable because it depends
on the particular society.
The societies have to be
agile and able to
deal with change.
So, I would expect it to change.
So that's not what
I'm going towards.
In fact, that's what I'm
trying to defend against.
Okay. We'll come to
some more of that.
Again, this is not
the kinds of things I think
you guys are concerned about but
I'll go ahead and
leave the slide in.
When I say that
AI's place in ethics,
it doesn't have to be a moral
agent or a moral patient.
What I'm trying to
say is that we don't
have to take it as
something we have to
give that kind of consideration.
That doesn't mean that we
can't take moral action.
All right. So, what
is moral actions?
If you have a behavioral
context that affords
more than one possible
action and first of all,
the society believes that some
or one of those actions is
more socially beneficial and
the individual is able
to recognize that,
then in that case I would
call that a moral action.
When you have to
make this decision,
whether you make a more
or less moral which
is more or less socially
sanctioned action.
I've deliberately again set
this up in a way to make it
totally easy to build
and you can talk about it
in things like monkeys.
So, monkeys will punish
other monkeys that aren't
doing the right thing,
that don't give food calls,
or apparently they'll even all
get a whole troop barking at
a dominant monkey that's
being too abusive
of its position of power and
beating up another
monkey too much.
So, you can talk about
that kind of action in
monkeys with a pet.
If you come home and
the dog's pooed in the middle of
the rug and you
think the dog knows
better than this and
you shout at the dog.
The dog probably thinks you knew
better than to come home at
12 at night and that's
why I pooed there.
So we are both
sanctioning each other.
But nobody outside of
your household is going to
consider the dog to be
a moral legal agent or whatever.
But you're acting within
the society of your family,
that you thought
the dog knew what
its options were and that
it chose the wrong one.
So, I'm not saying the AI
has to be a moral when I say
that we don't need
to make AI out to
be moral agents or
moral patients.
Okay. All right. Yes. So yes.
Just to be controversial,
monkeys, children, pets, women,
slaves and robots can
autonomously select moral
actions without being
held to be moral or legal agents
by their wider society.
I'm not saying I support
all those solutions.
I'm not saying that I
think it's a good idea
to consider some people to not be
responsible or to own
their own actions or property.
But I'm saying that those
are the kinds of decisions
societies have previously made.
I think it's very
important to realize that
when we talk about human justice,
it's not about like maintain
some kind of balance,
a lot of it is about dissuasion.
So, one of the things
that I'm going
here with this set of things,
I'm realizing that
I've put too many
interesting talks together and
not drawn quite enough threads,
but where I'm going with
this is it doesn't
make sense for the AI
to be set up as a legal person,
because we're not going to
be able to sanction it.
So, we can still have it taking
legal actions but not
be the legal agent.
So, monkeys and pets are easily
dissuadable by things
like social isolation.
Being isolated is torture
for a social animal,
like fish that like to school,
they die of stress
when you take them
to an isolated situation.
It is torture for humans.
So, monkeys and pets are
dissuaded by the kinds
of things we do.
They may not care if they
lose their money but they
care about being isolated
from their families.
AI and Shell companies,
you can make it care about
money and things like that,
but they aren't dissuadable.
The whole point of
a Shell company
is that the people who are taking
the fall are not
the ones who mind.
That you've set
something up that can
go bankrupt and nobody
actually cares.
So, only makes sense
for a company to be
a legal person if
someone cares if
that company goes bankrupt.
I mean, if the people
who are making
the executive decisions of that
company care if it goes bankrupt.
So AI is the ultimate
Shell company,
and that's what I'm
trying to defend
against IN this slide.
If that was a little
too fast and loose,
we could go into
this really nice formal paper.
These two guys are
law professors.
This is just alphabetical.
He did most of
the good decisions.
He did most of the good writing.
But this came out last year.
So, my conjecture
here is that none of
things like consciousness,
language, and ethics,
are the things that mandate
moral subjectivity,
that we need to worry about AI as
being a moral agent
or moral patient.
Oops, I'm going to turn
down the sound on this.
So yes,
for billions of years
intelligence, consciousness,
agency, language,
morality, and divinity
have all been at least
seen as correlated.
But as we all know, correlation
is not equal to causation.
It drives me crazy when
people sit here and
worry about when is AI
going to become conscious.
We can build it to express
the different definitions
we have of consciousness.
That doesn't change
its moral status.
So for example, one of
the things that makes a
human incredibly valuable is
the fact that they're
not replaceable.
Once someone is dead
they're just gone.
AI you can backup.
So, even if you had
something and it
looks exactly like a person,
if you decided to
have one copy of it
then you don't have
the same kinds of
ethical obligations towards it.
So, yes, a substantial objective.
So, this is a complain
about philosophers who
confound these concepts
around a single term.
I do actually do robots too.
I'm just talking a lot here.
It's Aude Billard's robot,
that's my PhD student.
Anyway, what's interesting to
me about consciousness is why
only part of what we do is
accessible to
explicit description.
I think we understand that now.
As I mentioned,
the combinatorics problem,
you can't be worrying about
all the things all the time.
But also I think there's a
philogony that
language evolved from
the scope of the module
for planning
action sequences and
things like that,
and then it became
the means by which we
negotiate coalition
agreements with others.
This is why we can
do things like say,
"Who cares that women
didn't used to have jobs?"
Now we think it would be more
fair if women could have jobs.
The part of us that
used to do planning,
we also use it for negotiate and
coalitions and that's part
of creating fairness.
So, that's cool and we could
use AI to do that but again,
doesn't mean necessarily that
that has to be a moral agent.
So, what we experience
phenomenologically
as consciousness,
seems to be a point when we
update important models
and the time that
we are appropriate to that
is proportional to how
certain we are about that.
Again, all of us who work in
Machine Learning could
imagine doing this if we have
bottlenecks for
Machine Learning and we
allocate it to the problems
we're currently working on.
It's not necessarily
about choosing,
actually I don't know why
I threw this slide in
because this is
another great paper.
I really like it, but
it's a longer talk.
So, ask me to come back
to that if you want.
But my point is that
when we are conscious,
when we're able to
describe what we've done,
we seem to be in
this particular position
of updating our current models.
The same thing, we can do
exactly the same actions and
not remember having done them
in a different kind of context.
So, it's not just about
action selection.
I think it's about learning.
But again, I'm trying to
demystify consciousness and say,
"Look, that's not
the point either."
The point is moral agency
and moral patience,
and those are things that
we're collectively defining.
So we're not just trying
to discover whether
AI requires that motivation.
Going back to this,
remember I mentioned this before,
all of this stuff this
is what we're doing.
So, for those of you who
didn't raise your hands,
this is sort of what
a word vector is.
These are the words you're
trying to understand
what they mean, and
then you just say,
"How often did 'hat' occur within
some Window of maybe 10 words
of rock or paper or scholar,
and how often did
the word obscure."
Occur within these words
and, of course,
you do that with two million
other words or something,
but I can only draw
two dimensions,
and then you have vectors
that come from just these counts.
So, it's a very simple thing.
It's like a giant Excel
spreadsheet or something.
Then, you just measure
the cosine between these angles.
It's semantics.
That's saying how similar
in meaning are these words.
How related are they? So,
that's all that's going on
and this is how
search engines work.
That's why you can type in
four words and get a page
and it's not all that's going
on as you guys probably
know better than me,
but it's the basic
underlying technology
that first gets that
working for you.
For the science paper, we
used two different corpuses.
We used the Stanford one which is
the common crawl because
we needed to get all those names,
so it was like a lot of
relatively low frequency names
and we only got this from having
840 billion tokens of which
2.2 million were unique.
So, we got that from Stanford,
but we also did the same thing
using Word2vec and Google News.
Apologies, I don't
know if Microsoft
also has, I'm sure you do,
word embeddings that you
distribute and corpora.
It was the same except
for that they didn't have
enough African-American names in
the corpora silicon put
as the main article.
Anyway, the first thing
we did was this test.
This is the first implicit
association test paper.
The first one about finding
this way of recording
implicit bias
in individuals and they
knew this was going to
be really controversial,
so they thrive with something.
The first thing they
at least report
about is looking at the names of
flowers and names of insects and
pleasant things and
unpleasant things,
and they say, "Can we find
out that there's implicit or
implicit associations at least
if you want to count
biases or not?"
The flowers are more
pleasant than insects
and insects are more unpleasant
compared to each other.
Yes, she can find that
with corpus linguistics.
All right? I think this guy
really overlooked.
This is basically saying
counting words returns viscera.
So, even if you're
talking about phenomenological
consciousness,
we sort of have that.
So, even things like,
"When will AI become empathetic?"
Well, when the Amazon
started doing
recommendation services,
that was one when it was
becoming empathetic.
It's not empathy like we have,
where we generalize
from the models in
ourselves to figure out
what each other is doing,
which incidentally
is biased because it
makes us more able to
understand people
more like ourselves,
so it's actually one
of the mechanisms
by which we humans can distance.
I really like Paul Bloom's book
about against empathy.
It's like empathy shouldn't be
the foundation of
morality anyway.
But, the point is
maybe we can even do
better with AI because it's not
generalizing from itself from
an internal model based
on some experience.
It's generalizing from models
that we've built on other people,
so we can actually go out
and find out people all
over the world. What
were they doing?
Which ones most like you and
what are you're probably feeling
if you're doing that if
the other person tell
us how they felt?
So, what about phenomenological
consciousness?
What if we build
something that's so
amazingly smart that it
starts suffering like
we would and it just
can't tell us like a
person is in isolation?
People really worry
about this thing.
This is weird because
we're never going to
build something in chips
and wires that have
the same visual experience as
much as cows do and we eat cows.
This is a lucky cow
that's out in the field.
So, we're obliged to build AI.
We aren't obliged to and that
was the thing that I
first started writing
about in the papers
people actually
started reading back in 2007.
So, I think what actually
matters is the AI is already
superhuman and I'm sorry I spent
so long on the stuff I
didn't think mattered.
But, that is the stuff I
usually ask questions about.
So, I think it really
matters that we already
have superhuman AI.
People like oh but it's not just
to learn generally
like humans do.
Remember the thing
about the pigeons?
We have all the stuff that
were set up culturally and
biologically to learn quickly
and what a surprise we
can learn it quickly.
But, there's
no more general purpose
learning than Bayes rule.
I mean, come on you know that so.
So, yeah, AI's
already superhuman,
but people aren't
recognizing it as being so,
and then we can and saw
these kinds of hazards.
So, like the economic hazard,
I mentioned this before.
I just want to talk about
where does this come from.
Why are we having
this surging inequality.
I think part of the problem.
Well this is again this is
we have a paper next slide.
We have a paper
account about this,
but we think what's
going on is when you
introduce technology that
reduces the cost of distance,
then you're just going
to have fewer winners.
So, in the late 19th
century that was like
rail, it was telegraph.
So, the newspapers were
getting this and oil.
Oil was lighter and cheaper.
So, it's not that it eliminated
the cost of distance,
but massively reduced it.
So, if, say we're going to
go for beer after this,
and say we were actually
in a town not on a campus.
We wouldn't go to the best pub
in the entire town.
We would go to
some combination of
a good pub and one
that's near to us.
So, that's one of
the ways you can
have lots of pubs and lots of
people can get money But,
with all the sudden you can get
your newspaper across
the entire country
then there's
fewer newspapers because
everybody wants to go
get the New York Times,
or whatever.
Not my favorite newspaper
and so, whatever.
So, when the great
corpora happens,
some people say, "Oh,
there was just a war.
That's just a war.
It's not just the war.
As I mentioned before the war,
it was a massive shift
in spending.
The war was part of that.
The war effort was part of that,
but it continued beyond that
into through the Cold War,
a shift in Spain that
was redistribution.
Maybe it was when we were given
incredibly high amounts of
wages to uneducated white males.
But, somehow we were
getting money out into
the economy and we were
getting less inequality.
Literally in 1945, I
mean so this is FDR.
So, after one World War and
the financial crash of '28,
there was a coalition
between the elite and
the proletariat in
the Democrat Party in America,
and that was the New Deal
and that was
massive redistribution.
At the end of 1945,
globally we're sitting around in
Europe agreeing that
there would no longer be
wealth extraction and wealth
and the banking laws by which
national wealth
extraction occurred
were eliminated for about 20
years and then we innovated.
Because they figured out that
the countries in Europe,
they found into fascism
were the ones that
had the highest inequality
that the wealth is
being extracted
because they'd sort of
arbitrarily been part of
the set to have lost
the First World War.
So, we need to get everybody to
realize that we want to
get more into this area,
not that the '60s and '70s
were completely smooth either,
but it wasn't like a World War I.
Empirically, it turns out that
Gini coefficient is around 0.7.
We're not talking about
completely egalitarianism here.
We're not saying like socialism
is the same of everything.
You do want to get more money
to people that are
doing good work.
We're just talking about how
steep is the inequality.
This is actually people
who are got into
archive within the last week.
Again, I'm not going to
talk about it too much
but I was just on
slide but we started
from the assumption,
as I mentioned,
the speed question.
Why is inequality and political
polarization correlated?
What we assume in the model is
that in-group cooperation is
less likely to pay off well
but also less likely to fail.
What we showed was that if
the economy is getting worse,
it makes sense after
a certain point
to give up the
opportunity of having
a higher expected outcome
in order to make
sure that you have
at least enough outcome
so that you maintain
your solvency.
The trick here is that you
can't have a society without
the individuals being
able to survive.
So, you can only ask individuals
to give so much to society.
However, the interesting
thing is that
if the economy keeps
getting even worse,
so that you can't be solvent
just by doing that
in-group cooperation,
then you need to actually
desperately do something and
going to working with
the out-group works
makes sense again.
So, that's the suspect down here.
Then again in some context,
and I really don't like go into
this too much before we
get through peer review,
but we've shown this on a couple
of models that polarization,
it's much easier to
get gradual increase
than to get gradual decrease.
Again because that non-linearity
at that one point.
So, that might explain
why you tend to
see these big corrections
like the new deal.
Rather than like everything
to start slowly, relaxing again.
Anyway, I already
mentioned the legal one.
The assigning responsibility or
personhood to artifacts
or trying to tax them.
I'm sorry I know Bill Gates
thought we should tax robots.
Robots are not countable.
They're not like people.
If you set up a tax regime
on the individual robots,
then we're just going
to reprogram and
redesign the robots.
We all know that.
I'm actually one
of the people that
supports redistribution based on
the shift in the amount
of money a company is
worth from one company
one year to the next.
I mean actually I didn't
put the slide in.
So I'll just say this
relatively quickly.
I don't believe that we're
having free Internet
interactions.
I think that we're
bartering data.
We get data,
entertainment because we
like going on the Internet.
Companies get information
about us from that exchange.
Because it's not denominated,
it's not taxed so income tax
is not working right there.
But it can't even be denominated.
It's often years later
that you suddenly
find new value in the old data.
It doesn't make sense.
Income tax is not making
sense right now in
the context of Internet services.
That's why I think we have
to go back to thinking about
wealth tax which
incidentally is a lot
easier to have
a nice stable regulation
of wealth tax and income tax.
Income tax makes
all kinds of problems.
I think we really need to
think about major shifts.
But anyway, this is
just talking about.
In Europe, they're talking
about e-personhood
for two reasons,
partly because there's people
who want to make AI that will
be their friends and
lovers that they own.
So, that's the guys who are
going to go on television.
But then quietly there's things
like car companies
that are worried
about creating driverless cars
and how the liability
is going to work,
when Google and Apple are
saying, We'll be liable.
Of course, we'll take
all the liability on."
They have more money than
they can legally spend.
If you're like
a car company that's
being paying pensions and
everything for decades,
then that sounds scary.
But making them into legal
persons so that you can say,
"Hey company, I have an idea,
why don't you fully
automate part of
your business process and
then we'll allow you to
cap your tax and
legal liabilities by whatever
you pushed off into the robot.
This is why I first got into,
not first but why I got increased
into ramped up in
2007 well from people
who started talking
about ethical robots
in battle and I didn't
want people to push
the command decisions onto
a robot and say, "Oh bad robot."
But now I'm thinking
about this in
terms of legal liability.
Anyway, the European Parliament
asked the European Commission
to seriously consider
making laws of
e-personhood so that's why
we rushed this paper out.
We really dropped
our other projects and
got this paper out
to combat that,
and it turned out that
the commission is obliged
to take seriously
the Parliament tells it,
the EU is sort of a democracy
but they shut this thing
down in like four months.
But anyway, there are still
people talking about it.
For example Estonia,
and if Estonia
makes legal personhood
for any artifact,
all legal persons in
Europe have to be recognized
by all of Europe.
So that's a problem. We
already have this problem.
There's already
shell organizations
which some people if
you're into flossmoor you
might want to read [inaudible] talk
about companies as AI already.
My personal nightmare, and
this slide again is from
before both decides
to spent 30 billion,
something dollars a year
or something building
AI and also became
president for life.
But this is a concern that
people so don't want
to die that they
either they will believe
that this chatbot
that's trained on
their e-mail is themselves
or even if they don't believe it,
they just like
the idea of extending
their will as we do already
with legal wills about
like how this land can be
used or my wife will lose
all her wealth if she
remarries, things like that.
So people are already
trying to extend
their will after they die.
I really worry about
people doing this
with data "trusts" or
something or legal persons.
Anyway, closer to home,
in software development,
I used to be really angry
at several developers at
Microsoft that were coming
to policy events and saying,
"You can't held us accountable
because that would mean we
can't use deep learning and
you lose the magic shoes."
But that all changed.
That changed sort
of midway in 2017.
Everybody got a message
about accountability
and transparency
being fundamental and human
standardness being
fundamental values.
I think Microsoft is
absolutely being
the biggest adult
in the room right now about this.
I have been very
clear about this.
But anyway, in the worst case,
the AI is inscrutable as humans.
We don't know what
the rates are doing in
human brains either but
we still audit companies.
We don't look at
the accountants synapses.
You can disagree.
You could say but with
at least an accountant,
we can put them on
the stand we just saw that.
An accountant goes on
the stand and says,
"I absolutely believe
that Manafort
knew what Gates told me
to do or something."
So, you can still
talk to someone.
But again, we're
really discussing
whether we believe
that person or not.
In technology, we can
actually do better.
The stuff we're doing
is facilitating,
mandate transparently on
this accounting mechanism.
We could be doing
things like keeping
our software and visual logs on
Git or at least
in-house and be able to
show what we changed?
Why we changed it?
When did we train?
What library did we train?
Are system on?
Why don't we do it in?
We have the black boxes.
I mean this is great.
There hasn't been
a fatal car accident in
autonomous driving that
we haven't found out
exactly what happened
within a few days,
that we knew what the robot
saw and what the robot did.
It may take longer to find
out why it did that but
we have incredible accounts
unlike when humans hit people.
So, where are we going with that?
We can keep that stuff
and that's a standard
because the current industry has
tons of liability and
they're very good at this.
But the rest of our industry
could do this too.
Wish we had approved
due diligence.
This is what people have
done already with AI.
In Germany, there was a car case
where somebody had a stroke.
I don't want to go through,
this is a long story.
That's what you want on Q&A.
But the point was
the car company is able to show
that there was no way
they could have told the
person that had a stroke.
It was just incredibly bad luck.
How much of software industry
could do that if something
went wrong with AI?
That they could prove
that they've done
everything that they
could possibly have done.
That was a state of
the expectations.
There's no reason.
I think we need
to know which code we linked
to on [inaudible] products.
Which data we trained
with and where that
data providence is.
We can do that.
I just felt obliged
to say that actually
transparency is what we
work on at Bath it's for
real time domestic systems
like new game characters
and little robots.
So, this is because we
don't have enough money,
we had build to
this thing by hand.
But this is the priorities
of the system.
The system has
hierarchical priorities,
basically behavior trees.
This came out of my PHD.
You can see from
the lining up in real time
what is doing and when we expose,
not quite this much detail
just usually that top level,
the priorities to people,
even ordinary users get
better what's really
going on with the robot.
It's great. One of the things
we're looking at now
is if we get these robots
to work at all,
it won't give us
the new version of Android.
It's like three years
behind Android.
But once we get
the rights to work,
we're going to see
whether the human format
interferes with people's
ability to understand.
Because we do have a little
money now but meanwhile,
my student couldn't wait
because he just graduate.
So, he put a little bee costume
on that robot and that
already changed how people
responded to the
transparence information.
Anyway, active research
with my students right now,
but anyway back to moral.
You guys know this right?
Do I need to explain what
happened with
Cambridge Analytica?
I assume everybody has heard
about this at this point.
This is something that
unites my two countries.
It doesn't matter, it's just
politics. Well, it matters.
I mean this matters. This is
the scariest thing
I actually read
in 2017 which is really
saying something.
I'm going to go ahead
and do I have the sound
turn on again? We'll see.
>> As a general, as
a retired general,
we have an army of
digital soldiers.
What we are now,
what we call them,
I call them because this
was an insurgency folks.
This was run like an insurgency.
This was irregular warfare
at its finest in politics,
and that story will
continue to be told
here but we have what we
call citizen journalists.
>> Yeah, so I think the stuff
matters. That's right, yeah.
So, I think it's
really essential and this
is something I'm telling
people that are in
government that we hold
people to the standards.
You can't magically know
how people are going
to use your software,
but you can say that
there are standards that
most people in that system said,
for example, "We
won't let you see
the personal data
that we've collected,
but if you tell us,
maybe I'll give advertisements
to a person like a kind of
person you're looking
for but we're
not going to just
give you their data."
Then, other people
say, "Yeah, sure.
Here, have their data."
If you can show that
80 percent of people knew
that was wrong and 20 percent
people did it anyway,
well, those 20 percent
should be held to account.
Despite the obvious
reference here,
I don't know for sure and
I trust the courts
of law to do this.
But if they find that
something is wrong,
I hope they get really hammered.
I'm not saying eliminate it,
but there's a lot of
hammering that could be
done and could still be afforded.
I mentioned this earlier, this
slide you might recognize.
The second half of that slide
is for the automatic
kind of bias.
One thing you can do is
compensate with design,
I think that's what humans are.
Like I said, explicit
versus implicit memory.
So, you just know not to
extrapolate the idea.
Ignorance though, this is
why I threw this slide in.
It's because, look,
the conversation we had earlier.
Diversified test and iterate
and improve. That's the thing.
When something comes
out of ignorance,
we can fix it, we can
improve it and that's great.
Yeah. Then, the only way
to handle deliberate is
by audits and regulation.
So we've got to expose
our stuff out to help
people be able to
prove that stuff.
Okay. So, this is
at the last slide.
I know you guys are
dying for that by now.
ICT systems have designs
and have architecture;
and architects, as
undergraduates, learn about laws,
they learn about policy,
they go on and get licensed,
they learn how to work
with governments and
urban planners because at
some point in the past,
we could decide.
It used to be
an average person could build
a building and
sometimes they fell
on people or they stuck
it somewhere and it
clogged up traffic We
don't accept that anymore,
and I just think we've
gotten to the stage now.
We, as computer scientists,
have matured what our buildings
are falling over on people
and affecting everyone.
So we need to start teaching
our undergraduates how to
work with government and
we need to be collaborate through
government in order to make
the world stable enough
that we can flourish.
The rate of successful,
sustainable innovation
is what matters,
not just the speed to market.
So, thank you. I'm sorry
that ran a little
longer than I meant.
>> [inaudible] for questions?
>> Believe it or not,
there's still 20 minutes left.
>> Maybe I'll start with one.
You had a slide,
I'm probably going to be making
mistakes and reiterating.
>> Well, please.
>> You have a kind of
definition for moral behavior
that was talking
about selecting
actions that optimize
the societal benefits
or societal value.
Do you see this as
a prescriptive way of
coding up AI agents?
>> This is such a cool question.
I have another one
hour long talk about
this question because with humans
even, one of the things is,
that's why I talked about it,
is it said that a society
considers an action
to be moral when
it does a thing that society
decides that it wants.
So, I was doing something for
about a decade before now,
starting about 2008, working on
understanding why there's
cultural variation
in public goods investment.
Why? Because of that stuff
I told you guys
before about culture
being a public good,
so I was trying to understand why
only one species has language.
I was working in public goods,
and then actually
the US military asked me to work
on cultural variations so
I put these two things together.
It turns out that
different people
treat people that
invest in the public.
Different regions
of the world have
people who tend to treat
people differently than
invest in the public good,
and some of them
actually punish those
who give more than they
do to the public good.
If they're allowed to
because this is all
secret like
a rat lab experiments.
So, if they could
figure out the sneaky
way like vandalism or
something to punish the people
who have been giving
to the public good,
they will and actually
have more tendency to do
that in places that have
lower rule of law and lower GDP,
and unfortunately those are
two correlated things, too.
The economy is always
complicated like that.
So, the point is that you have
to take care of yourself.
There's actually an expression
in Eastern Europe in
Slavic languages that
if you don't steal,
you steal from your family.
So, there's a baseline
of making sure that
you stay alive
and that you need to be able
to do individual investment.
So, I think part of what
society tends to do is
try to get you to invest in
society and so our culture
tends to do that,
and so it's probably
slightly overshooting
the level at which you should
be investing in the social level.
So to give an immediate
example in AI,
when Google had
their driverless cars
going around in Mountain View,
they had the strict rules
of the road about what
you're supposed to do at
a four-way stop and
the Google cars were
never going to go,
and they had to build into
it what people always do,
which is that at some point
you take the initiative,
you don't wait till
every other car
has come to a full stop
and then go.
You have to say, "Okay, I've
been here long enough,"
and start going.
I don't think we
necessarily have to
build our AI up to
the paragon of ideal morality,
but I do think we
need to, in fact,
I think you necessarily have
to equilibrate that
a little bit more.
That's one of the weird
interesting things that
all this is going to bring
up. We actually are.
This interacts badly,
accountability interacts
badly with privacy,
but I think it's
a fixable problem.
I'm just saying that it was
something we have to defend,
but I think we are going
to become much more
explicitly aware of
a lot of the things we
had previously not been aware
of because again explicitly
we were doing things,
we're being encouraged to do
things where in some sets are
natural but turned out
to be good and useful.
Does that answer the question?
>> Yeah, and I actually
have a follow-up question
which is that kind of
assumes that there is
a common understanding of
what socially good is.
I'm sure you thought about
there could be cases
where a solution could
be better for the majority
and there could be
another solution
that is worse for
the majority but
definitely significantly
better for the minority,
and this is really
real with all of
the perceptive systems
where people talk about
trading off percentage
they can receive
for something in
return and so forth.
>> Yeah. What this
means and this is,
I actually wrote a paper
about this while I
was still a PhD student too,
that the closer AI gets
to human intelligence,
the more what we're
talking about it.
That is fundamentally what
political scientists talk about
when they talk about democracy,
defending the rights
of the minority.
Half of us dropped out of
undergraduate or whatever
and blindly go and just
do a lot of programming
and not realizing
these entire disciplines are
working on these problems.
So now, we are society.
We have to deal with
all those problems,
the defending the rights of
the minority and the fact
that there isn't a particular
absolute correct solution.
That solutions may be different
in different contexts.
That's the kind of
complexities that law
and politics have had to
deal with for a millennia.
Yeah, absolutely.
>> It's an ambiguous question
but bear with me.
>> That's all right.
>> Should or could
a moral agent is such without
being part of a society?
How can we be a moral agent
without being part
of that society?
>> Okay.
>> Or should you?
>> Right. First of
all, we need to
disconfirm these two terms.
So, there's an agent being
moral taking us moral actions,
and there's the moral agent,
as I just described,
which is the thing
that's being held
accountable for its actions.
>> Then backtracking, can
you be a moral agent?
>> I don't think, for either
of those two
definitions actually,
you can be without in society
because the society is one that's
declaring the rules
that the person
being moral is following,
and for the moral agent
that's been defined
by the society,
it's basically the side of
responsible actors
where obviously
the society what defines it.
So for both of those,
I think you need a society to get
the definitions for the morality.
I don't think that morality
exist in a vacuum,
but that's okay
because you're not
going to get intelligence
in a vacuum either.
The microbial will
totally take it out.
All of us are intelligent
cognitive species.
We all have a social.
If nothing else, we
come from parents.
We're all the products
of sexual reproduction.
So, yeah.
>> I'm really curious
about your last piece,
about how to control
that third threat,
I'm just like malicious AI
and specifically regulation.
So, what are some of
the government regulations that
you foresee and what would you
recommend for those of us
in the technical community
to stay up-to-date on
those and get to that
>> Well, the main thing
that we're trying to do
in the UK at least
which is one of
the most- I've been in
academics since 2002.
So, I've been an adult
since I don't know when,
but basically I've
been a professional in
this particular
discipline since 2002,
so I'm just more
familiar in Britain.
But at least in Britain,
we don't feel like we
need a lot of new laws.
We just need to
start applying them
into ICT and into software,
which is something
we hadn't been doing
before because people
didn't understand it.
So, I think the
main thing is if we
maintain the current standards
of accountability,
then that will encourage-
so if I just say we.
If the government, which I
do feel we're all part of,
if the government part
of us maintains
accountability into
the software industry
and starts understanding it,
and actually McCrock had
a great interviewing
Wyatt about this.
Of course we're always watching
new industry for a while for
a few decades and then we
get involved. But anyway.
So, if they start
pursuing accountability,
then we, the other part of we,
the software industry,
are going to be highly
motivated to be able
to have transparency.
At least sufficient transparency
so that we can prove that
we've done due diligence.
Right? So, because you're
not going to have
perfect transparency.
I already said this
to one of you.
I think it was you, today.
But there's this thing called the
map of Germany problem and
I've no idea why it's Germany.
But the point is that a map
of Germany that was perfect,
that had every detail,
would be the same size as
Germany and it would be no use.
This is actually
another re-framing of
the whole box thing
about all models
are rhymed but some
are useful, right?
So, there is of
course a trade-off about how
much transparency you can have,
how much explainability you can
have, those kinds of things.
But we can motivate
companies to make the
trade-off themselves
internally rather than
mandating the amount of
transparency by just
maintaining accountability,
and accountability is
actually already in the law.
It just hasn't been pursued
into the technology
companies before,
and now the governments are
realizing technology
companies matter.
So, maybe they will
just start pursuing it.
So, what we're trying
to say is that
we don't really need
so much new laws and so
we need new practice and
just better education in
the prosecutor's offices.
Actually, again,
talking to the people,
I've only talked to
three people so far,
I don't crap up names but it
sounds like Microsoft is already
realizing this is
a big corporate entity.
You can cast in the positive way,
which is that you
want the software
to be doing what's
best for society.
You can also say that
you want to avoid
big corporate
liability cost, right?
Those come for free together.
>> I have a question,
there's this interesting- let's
quote the [inaudible] I
like to hear your thoughts.
Does the opinion or the school
of thought that says,
"Let's create Artificial
Intelligence"
and the school of
thought that says,
"No, that's fool's errand let's
create assist of intelligence."
Something that is always
partnering with a human,
cannot have
independent behaviors,
it's always at the service of
[inaudible] prosthesis
if you may of a human.
What do you think things should
go if you have a choice?
>> Okay. So, I think
that that's a great question,
I'm glad you asked it.
You're not quite
using the language
I presented here but that's okay.
Because you're using for
Artificial Intelligence,
so I briefly mentioned
a lot of people are
using for Artificial
General Intelligence.
By which they mean all kinds of
contradictory things because
it's not a coherent thing,
and I was mostly talking
about the omniscient AGI.
But you're talking about
the human-like AGI,
that there's something
that's really is human
unconscious and all those
other kinds of things.
So, a lot of
this was about that and
it didn't come together,
so now I have a chance to
bring it together,
so that's great.
Thank you very much
for your question.
The point is that we can't
create something out of
silicone that is an agent in
our society as it's
currently run.
Because the sanctions that
we do to keep each other
from doing the wrong things
aren't going to
work on a machine.
Right? Machines are not
going to have- I mean,
you could build into a robot
a bomb and a timer and the timer
is set when there's
no other person in the room and
the bomb is going to
go off if there's
no person around
for five minutes.
Okay. You can say, well that's
kind of like humans
that they don't like to
be isolated because- but it's
not liking to be
isolated to know that you're
just going to blow up.
Right? Watch your investment
not being blown up.
In humans and in fish
and everything else,
there's a systemic stress.
Right? If we have
well-designed AI that we can
be responsible and accountable
for and all those things,
you're going to have things
like systemic stress.
You are going to have
modularity and you're
going to have ways of
knowing it's going to
be more separable.
So, I don't think there's
a safe way to build
a system- basically,
I think there's no way that
we can build a system that we
would regulate like we
regulate other people.
That was why I just said I think
even legal personhood has
been overextended right now,
which is why we're having
these problems with
the Shell corporations
as long as people are
building buildings
deliberately to make them
go bankrupt so they
can launder money.
Right? So, that's
the kind of thing that I
think that we see when
we're going out and
building these other people.
I mean, I understand that,
I want to do it too.
Why do you think I got into AI?
I understand the desire
to procreate,
that's a very fundamental part
of life that we have
a desire to procreate.
But I think it's better.
I mean there's a lot
of things you can want
that aren't necessarily
good things for you.
Right? I think it's one of
those things that it's
better for us to figure out
how to procreate in terms
of making humans at
the core as more as
the things that are
the responsibility or
the sources of the creativity.
Right? So, you can
project your legacy in
other ways through your writings
or even through your AI chart
thought thing, right.
But you don't make
that the legal person
or the moral person
or the moral patient,
sorry in this case,
that's competing
with your biological legacy.
I don't see that's coherent.
Now, I understand that
people think well,
humanity is only going
to be around for
four billion years
because that's how
long the sun is going to last.
But actually, there's been
no hominids that have
lasted more than a couple of
million years as a species.
But even with technology,
there is like
how many software formats
or data formats have been
around for 80 years.
Right? Humans make it for
80 years and yet we think
that AI is going
extend ourselves,
this is this mathematical fallacy
that I was talking before we.
It's not math, it's not going
to be perfect and eternal.
So, I think that we're never,
that was the cow slide,
we're never going to reproduce
something that's going to
have the same phenomenologies
we have or even as much
as I could have thought
of fruit fly let alone a
cow or another mammal.
Right? But we can
build things that say,
don't shut me off or whatever.
This is my earliest work
so people looking at
my earliest works,
it's just like, just
build in the back up.
Even if your best friend does
turn out to be a robot and then
somehow you have some way of
freeing it, you don't have to.
You should still if
you're in a fire,
you save the Shakespeare.
Well, it's probably
backed up too,
so you can save
a toddler or something,
leave your best friend there
and your best friend comes
walking up the hands you the
new build for its new body.
Right? It's not a problem.
So, I think we need
to understand.
Believe it or not,
there were a lot of slides cut.
We have to understand
that it's okay,
that our our society
is based around the fact
that we're a bunch of apes,
and that our morality and
our social intuitions and
all those things are shared with
a lot of other chimpanzees.
Right? You're not going to have
something that has
the same motivations,
whether social or ambitions
or whatever that chimpanzees have
that you build out- I mean,
you could absorb it from like
I said from, from our text.
Right? So, you could probably
get a blueprint that way,
but it's not going
to be empathically
from the inside
motivated the same way.
So, I think it's a mistake to
lead people down that direction
because they do want it so badly.
You said this is going
to be the last question,
I thought there are seven
minutes left, that's not true.
But my answer just
took six minutes.
There's only one minute left.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Okay.